[Music]
all right so the political climate right
now
is at an all-time fever i feel like oh
no because it's voting time oh yeah it's
hot
hot climate just like our actual weather
right now we're in october and it's
[ __ ] hot do you know [ __ ] hundred
something
they had a um they didn't even do the
debate dude they just did the town hall
just cancel the [ __ ] out of the debates
really is that what happened
yeah they were supposed to have a debate
uh a couple days ago they're like what's
the point
they ended up having just town hall
meetings so what is that didn't biden
have one and then trump had
a different meeting like live on a
different network
and so they were trying to i guess trump
was trying to compete for ratings yeah
yeah who won who won the ratings battle
i don't know i do not
name the town hall meeting is that just
people like asking questions yeah well
you have like a a a interviewer i guess
and then you do your thing
and then you do q and a's with the with
the audience
so yeah um so all this political uh
fever uh has gotten a lot of citizens
up in a bunch as well and we gotta check
the temperature of our people
yes and recently uh on a southwest
flight
from tampa to dallas uh an incident
happened
and it is quite uh i don't know it's
just i i
still have a hard time processing the
out it's yeah you see for yourself don't
ruin southwest they have cheap flights
come on dude
this is uh is the argument i guess uh a
confrontation between the flight
attendant and a
black man and uh the person recording
is in the same friend group or work
group as the black man
and uh and also the person sitting next
to the camera person
all right here we go so we're not
allowed to eat with our masks off is
that what you're saying
[Laughter]
take off his mask no i'm sorry i'm his
legal counsel
is it not your policy that he can wear
him to take off his mask i'm wearing
this
guy he's like let me put mine on here
you gotta load it up in this
[ __ ]
can you tell us the policy that prevents
him from taking his mask off while he's
eating please
i was not here for the present the crew
has denied okay but you're seeing him
with eating so please tell me the policy
tell me who
lawyers are gangster with this mask
the hat says uh black voices for trump
something like that um
[Music]
there's a reason why he's not answering
clarify are we are not allowed to take
our masks off to eat on this plane or
not
listen to the fly crew and follow their
instructions so
answer the questions he's freaking out
because he doesn't want to get in
trouble
he put his mask on he took it off when
he started eating the nuts
that was good i was sitting right here
so
can we just take the publicity it's not
a publicity sign it's trying to make you
follow
policy indiscriminately
and and impartially okay
so do you follow your policy
indiscriminately and impartially or do
you just do this for people whose
message you don't like
ooh is this of a podcast
yes okay so this is the point
is this for tick-tock this is a great
time
when we eat yeah and that's what they
said in germany too right
just come on oh [ __ ] so
yes that is uh so
the crew was told by
the pilots to kick them off they said
the
crew the flight attendant crew yeah it
just seems like a random
escape group the guy that went up and
asked him to leave
he was saying i wasn't here was working
on the behalf of
the staff the crew that didn't want they
don't want him to be on this particular
place southwest
that's crazy so this can be a
discrimination lawsuit
because it seems like he was ousted for
being a trump supporter
yes so he was sporting a hat that said
black voices for trump
and he had a mask that said trump on it
and i i think i you know for one
i get kind of weirded out with people
that are super trump
you know like i i get weird feelings for
some reason that's why you gotta carry
both masks and go oh [ __ ] my bad who's
neighborhood
you're connor and kabir
can i say here yeah but like oh i'm
sorry can they leave
he should have had a biden hat and a
trump mask
there we go that's the move there you go
mine [ __ ] with
both yeah so i i get i get weirded out
with trump people but
that's so strange i don't know in this
instance it's kind of like
there's there's a line that's being
crossed here at this point where he
didn't do anything
i don't know and he's eating nuts he's
eating nuts come on so the official
statement
uh from southwest airlines was that um
they wanted him off the flight because
he was told multiple times while
boarding to
put on a mask according to them he
didn't have a mask on while boarding
while boarding i see
multiple times to put it on and so
the video only shows us when he's
sitting down and at this point
well actually throughout the whole video
he never really even had the mask on it
was just
under his chin we never really did chin
diaper yeah i like that
um we've never actually seen the mask on
so perhaps the airline has a point
to you know to be said um but based on
unless he was eating nuts the whole time
if he was just like eating fingers yeah
just one at a time very slowly but then
i agree with the airline then if it's
like you're boarding
you are actually passing by a lot of
people you should be having your mask on
you can eat when you sit down and if
that's what happened
and because based off of what we saw in
the video
they were saying like the the man in the
video was just like
i did comply i put it on as soon as you
told me and and then the woman is saying
wait so
he has to have it on like he can't take
it off when he's eating or whatever
they're focusing hard on that part
and that's the part that i was like
that's [ __ ] up like he didn't do
anything wrong but then if it's
the boarding part rewarding part then
i'm like then yeah he was not being
compliant you don't really get the
context
before the video yeah we don't know what
happened before but then the guy
um the guy that's being kicked off the
flight he did say well i put it i mean
you guys told me to put it on i did put
it on so
he also admits that he had it he didn't
have a mask on initially
that he'd put it on whenever he was told
told to but then
now the flight crew is telling him that
he didn't i guess he didn't act fast
enough or he was told to
one it's tricky because like so there's
also people that just don't even like
masks
i was on a flight maybe like three weeks
ago
and you know the people that pretty much
do the bare minimum yeah
it's like here have to like and you can
tell how pissed off the flight attendant
and then she was really professional
where she didn't single anyone out or
whatever but she kept saying like over
and over again like
please cover your nose if you're wearing
a mat and just everyone in the flight
can tell it's just that one person
please pull it over your nose it doesn't
if you can see your mustache
you're not wearing the mask correctly
like over and over and over
so that could be what happened like
before we just didn't see that entire
yeah that would be kind of cool if we
just saw the whole process
and it's like and we can tell yeah bro
they have to ask you like 10 times
that's [ __ ] up yeah yeah if it's like
10 times you never put it on until the
10th
time people are saying kids more than
twice and it's like
okay then you [ __ ] up right people
love wearing their masks like this
it's like it's like what's the point
they'll say they'll tell you please put
the mask over and they're like but it's
it is on they'll do that they'll do
semantics oh um
at that point you should get punched in
the mouth i'm like oh no
that's exposed i i mean there's also
human error and i'm not saying for this
guy's case but in my case
like um i remember i was at the airport
and i totally [ __ ] forgot because i
sat down to eat a sandwich
and then they called my name so i was
like oh [ __ ] so then i got up
and then i went to the counter and
they're like you got to put your mask on
i was like
oh [ __ ] yeah you don't remember uh
especially if your mind is distracted
and whatever um so i'm like there's so
many
cases where you do got to remind people
and it to me it just depends on how they
react if i could watch
what this guy did he's like all right
[ __ ] you
i'll do it versus like oh [ __ ] thank you
i'm sorry yeah right
then i'm like i can probably tell yeah
you were being an annoying little [ __ ]
and you deserve to be kicked off yeah
you're being an [ __ ] let's say he was
complying and being apologetic
and he was good and he was whatever
because it could go both ways he could
have been an [ __ ] they could have
been discriminating because he's a trump
uh supporter we don't know but the way
it's painted though from the video
footage that we do have it does look
like it's just pure discrimination
yeah but it's his friend of course of
course that's what i'm saying i'm like
oh yeah
from a biased point of view true and
then because it's it's
filmed by a friend uh who's on this
person's side
um it also kind of feels and the fact
that someone in the background says
uh stop with the publicity stunt or
whatever yeah
what if it is a publicity stunt what if
it is a means to
um create some viral video showcasing
how
intolerant the flight crew is you never
know these yeah and then at the end
they're like well that's what the
germans did
right right yeah the first part when she
immediately go
it wasn't because he's eating it's
because of that hat and that mask you
guys are against it
i didn't even recognize she's framing
the narrative yeah
already by saying that and bringing in
the germany he does have like i mean
just in this like on the web on the on
the thumbnail he does do a little smirk
thing that kind of rubs me in the wrong
way
yeah so i don't know i saw that too
right now kind of made me
it's like let's annoy them antagonize
them let's get to the point where we get
discriminated and then we can
we can catch them in the act because it
seems like everybody does that nowadays
right
a lot of people play do that really
can't you really can't uh
trust a snippet anymore no you really do
need context you need to see what
happened
and if think of it this way too like if
southwest
really had grounds to kick this guy off
the flight for not wearing a mask
do you think if it was the opposite way
say he was wearing his mask the whole
time
do you think and just because they
didn't like the fact that he had a trump
hat and a mask on do you think the
southwest airlines and flight crew
would go through the trouble of just
kicking this guy off the flight because
it's like what happens after that
it's like there if if people find out he
was wearing his mask the whole time and
he did everything the way he needed
there's other witnesses
yeah for once i would like someone who's
got like
in this tense situation to go are you
gonna keep it on
all right all right let's let them go
keep it on
you know and then it changes the sh the
energy
it does like even like when cops get
into situations
where they're getting called out by the
public and [ __ ] goes down it's kind of
like
it happens sometimes when they're not on
camera where they're like
all right [ __ ] it but then i think when
the camera is on and the tenseness
happens now they gotta hold their ground
now that you know
the e-gag gets [ __ ] up man it's a
tough one i don't know
can you spread the corona virus through
farting yeah
fauci said that two weeks ago oh i
remember that yeah yeah
i was wondering if like it's okay to
just maybe like
cover the face with the new fart
well you do have a lot of layers of
clothing that are covering the gas
yeah your underwear is kind of like your
ass mask
i like ass masks
you